thank you james mark and miles uh
they are going to be discussing today
snowflake and desk how to scale
workloads using distributed fetch
capabilities i'll let you guys introduce
yourselves um so please go ahead hey
everybody thank you for joining today
this session is titled uh snowflake for
desk
and
we'll have three of us on here today to
kick us off here my name is miles adkins
i'm a partner sale engineer here at
snowflake and i cover our ai
ml ecosystem from the partner
perspective james yeah hi everyone my
name is james perveaux i'm a desk
maintainer
and also the legal resource engineer at
coiled where
we work on things like desk and other
projects in the pi data space
hi my name is mark i work at snowflake
as a software engineer i mostly work on
our open source python projects such as
sql chemi and our python connector
great thank you for that mark
so just to kick us off here just to set
some context
for i know i know snowflake has got
gained a lot of popularity over the last
uh several years um you know i just want
to give you an intro to kind of what is
snowflake
and what differentiates us from
a lot of the other cloud data warehouses
out there
and so snowflake is really a scalable uh
data platform as as a service whereas a
lot of the other cloud technologies in
the data warehouse space we're really
just
um you know on
uh
technologies that were kind of lifted
and shifted to the cloud
uh snowflake was architected on the
cloud so
um what that means is we were able to
take uh you know scalable services like
s3 and ec2
and really architect and build off those
technologies as opposed to
you know just bringing up postgres to
to the cloud
and what makes us unique here is really
our three layer approach
at the bottom layer we have our kind of
centralized storage we really believe in
this idea of
you should have just one copy of the
data and
if you want to share that data somewhere
you just you just initialize and govern
a share as opposed as opposed to
making another copy of that data
doing some sort of ftp process or just
emailing your data and then um going on
from there we find that often
that
you know those pain points cause a lot
of disruption time and value to
a
value loss to a company and so
you know we wanted to keep all the data
in one place
the second layer here is our compute
layer which is uh completely isolated
from storage so storage and computes you
can kind of
scale up to
your your desired levels there and
you can think of this as if you deploy
on google cloud
they have their own compute service if
you put deploy on aws we have ec2 and
same for azure
this allows you to scale all of your
workloads both up and out as you need to
up meaning you know i have more and more
and more data that i'm starting to work
with in my data platform
you can get and request a bigger and
bigger
uh instant size
and then out meaning hey you know i'm on
boarding a new uh set of users or
um
you know i've let a new group in my
organization
get access to snowflake and i'm starting
to see my queries my number of queries
per second
you know continue to rise we give you
the ability to spin up more and more and
more servers
in a kind of a multi-cluster compute
fashion to to service kind of the needs
of your users as well
and then the last layer here and this is
really kind of what we call the the
brain of snowflake is our cloud services
layer this is where we handle all the
stuff like uh security and governance uh
our sharing and collaboration features
um
you know query query optimization
and then of course also kind of that sas
layer as well so this is kind of how we
deliver snowflake to you as a service
where
you really only pay for what you consume
you don't have to spin it up
let it run idle for a while it's really
a quasi serverless
experience for you
and so what this enables
um this this data this this data cloud
platform is
the ability to ingest really all three
types of data structured semi-structured
and unstructured data as well
enabling six distinct workloads all on
one platform whether you're doing data
engineering you have
different types of data science
applications or you're just building you
know more general data applications
all of those can be powered by snowflake
and then of course being able to reach a
variety of different types of data
consumers
now to to go a little bit deeper here
we know that snowflake
is
still not going to be able to cover the
entirety of
kind of the the mass amount of data
workloads out there
um what we've kind of
engineered is
a bunch of uh a big ecosystem of
connectors whether it's our python
connector which we're going to go into
in a little bit here
uh jdbc connector odbc connector
um you know for for for you to really be
able to hook into the snowflake platform
now
uh
for a while the only way to really move
data across from one app to another was
uh through a through a single pipe and
so there was no way to really
do any sort of parallel
parallel data movement between snowflake
and in your application and so with that
um
i'm happy to pass it over to here to
mark who's going to walk through
our latest innovation where you can now
that
really grab your your result sets
and uh you know read and work with those
in parallel
mark
thanks my nose
um could you please go to the next slide
so i would like you all to imagine
dealing with a terabyte of data
it's hard because it's impossible to
hold it in memory all at once
unless you know you have some sort of
super expensive machine that is
for this reason
when a sequel korean snowflake returns a
large amount of results
it gets broken into smaller pieces
we call these result chunks
each of them are a few megabytes in size
and they can differ from one another
that i mean the sizes
um
then the different connectors will fetch
and convert these for the users to the
respective language specific objects
but as you can imagine
synchronously processing a terabyte of
data will still take quite a long time
even with optimal code
so the only way to scale past a certain
point in python
is to distribute the work between
multiple processes or machines
however this was impossible with our old
monolithic design
of the
of the result fetching mechanism
um because information that was vital to
processing
was discarded as soon as it was consumed
miles can you go to the next slide
please
so
this is where the idea of result batches
was born
they represent the result chunks
generated from snowflake in a one-to-one
fashion on the connector's side
um
we we set out with a few simple goals in
mind primarily
the result batches had to be standalone
this would allow them to be consumed
independently
without their own connection to
snowflake
to allow for easy distribution between
processes
these result batches had to be
serializable
to keep them standalone
this meant that we would need to
serialize some of their metadata in
addition
but we
we
we were careful because we didn't want
to lock users into a particular
parallelization method
for example if we were to enforce
multi-processing onto
the whole python connector then it would
just now work in aws lambda
to complement our existing ability to
convert
result
results into pando's data frames
we wanted to allow converting to arrow
tables as well this was a much requested
feature by our users
finally
and but still very importantly we didn't
want to break or regress performance of
pre-existing use cases
for non-distributed
result fetching
these still needed to have some sort of
pre-processing logic
so
so to kind of bring it all back together
in a nutshell the final design has all
of the result functionality pushed down
from the overarching result set level
to the individual result batch level
as an example
instead of iterating over the entire
result set
we iterate through each of the result
batches individually
nevertheless
we need to support our existing use
cases
to accomplish this we created a
resultset class
it composes multiple result batches
together using a simple iterator logic
and interface
this class also supports prefetching
chunks for consumption later
and it uses simple multithreading
this results set class
also serves as an example of how we
envision our partners
to implement their own concurrency
strategies
i would encourage partners to use it as
a starting point for their own designs
we also made sure that result batches
are lightweight replayable and most
importantly serializable
this is to make sure that they can be
distributed to other machines easily
we we also added some extra metadata
information to each of the result
batches
like their size and and this was to
allow people for more intelligent
distribution between processes
um
for me the the coolest part of this
project
uh was to see all of the new use cases
that it enables for our users
internally we had one of these
presentations where one of our sales
engineers presented a way of performing
deep learning
on all of these individual result
batches
and then once he had all of the
the resulting models he was then able to
merge them back together at the end
and and this enabled him not only to
push his computer
as hard as he could if he wanted to
but it also gave him the option to just
have it running in the background and
maybe you know
allow him to to run
another process in the foreground
without taking over his computer
i had no clue that something like this
was even possible before
so for this reason
i would like to ask you to reach out to
me and let me know how distributed
result fetching enabled you to do
something new
and with that um
i would give it over to james
yeah thanks mark um i'm gonna see if i
can share my screen
[Music]
your desktop one hopefully you see some
slides right now
yep let me
go ahead and put that into present mode
can you still see the slides or are you
seeing presenter notes and things like
that you'll see your slides here awesome
great thanks kyle thanks mark so yeah um
so i'm gonna sort of the second half of
this talk is um about integrating this
new distributed fetch capability from
snowflake with desk
um
so to kind of summarize so far on the
snowflake side so snowflake is a
centralized data storage service that
has a
highly optimized sql engine so um really
good at storing serving data and again
this this sort of incredible highly
optimized sql engine um however
snowflake itself
is sort of a data access
system which could and management system
which could benefit from more advanced
operations in python like for instance
machine learning or any other kind of
advanced analytic analytics you might be
used to in the pi data space
um so how do we go about sort of
connecting snowflake as a system to
python
um so
for instance there are a couple kind of
ways in which you can connect the two uh
the first is on the data ingestion side
so you may have some you know complex
data sets that you're you're working
with maybe you have some uh simulation
data
that's being displayed here um or some
weather data that you need to you know
sort of massage and process into a nice
form you can then store into a snowflake
um another option would be on the the
output side you may have some existing
data into in snowflake that you want to
run a bunch of machine learning calls
and you want to you know sort of apply
an actually a trained xg boost model to
an entire table and in snowflake
this is a really common thing we see at
financial institutions
um for example
uh desk is great at the sort of scalable
pi data solutions so a couple things to
know about das is that it is okay at
sql-like operations so this is really i
mean desk can do sql-like operations and
support some but it's not really a place
where it shines it's more a place where
it's snowflake
um desk itself also is not uh
it's not an integrated storage dust
itself isn't a storage system it's a
compute system
uh so gas does not
destin uh you know talk to storage
systems like snowflake but it itself is
more of a compute engine
places where desk does shine
are that it's great for sort of advanced
uh analysis um and machine learning it's
also really good at handling
non-traditional data so it can handle
tabular data uh for example sort of the
more sql friendly type data that's das
can handle because there's desk data
frame
which sort of is sort of a parallel
version of pandas
that handles tabular data incredibly
well desk also supports uh not so sql
friendly data sets so again going back
to um you know sort of
these complex maybe in indie array type
data sets that you might be using uh
projects like x-ray for for instance uh
das supports those types of data sets as
well
so this is sort of a summary of the last
couple slides the the take-home message
is snowflake is really good at data
storage and sql performance
um das does not shine in those those
areas but it does shine in uh the
machine learning space non you know
advanced analytics and not working with
non-traditional data
so both of these
sort of technologies um are sort of uh
sort of excel in certain spaces and we
can bring them together to kind of get
the best of all works we can get the the
best of data storage and sql performance
and the best of machine learning and
non-traditional data analysis by
combining the two
so now we moved to a technical question
of sort of how do we combine these two
technologies
there are a variety of ways in which you
can combine
snowflake and task and
sort of walk through uh all these
options that sort of have have uh been
used in the past and at the end i'm
gonna spend some time and highlight this
new uh native uh parallel reading uh uh
technology so sort of integrating the
stuff mark talk about this distributed
fetch into desk
um so the first option is to not use
task this is always a great rule of
thumb don't use dash if you don't have
to um if your data sets are small which
many are just use snowflake directly
snowflake has a python connector that
you can use to execute queries and fetch
you know pandas data frames um from
snowflake this is already available it's
super simple to use that's sort of the
pro um the con is it doesn't it doesn't
scale well so if your data sets um are
uh as as mark mentioned a terabyte large
uh in size and sort of larger than your
your uh local machines uh memory uh the
local memory on your machine you can't
fit it on your laptop say
doesn't scale to those situations
the next option is to use dask's read
sql table functionality
so this is great and that it allows you
to start using das
which allows you to have distributed and
larger than memory read price
um it uses uh sql output sql alchemy
under the hood so it can actually talk
to a snowflake but lots of other
database technologies as well so it
works on all major databases
um
so what happens under the hood here is
you can imagine having like a giant
table
of time series data um you can imagine
taking sort of the querying they get the
minimum and maximum and sort of get a
sense for the expected size of the data
the minimum maximum and time um and then
split up um that you know data set the
time series data set into a bunch of
smaller um sort of uniformly sampled uh
queries and then executing each of those
queries for each partition of this data
set in parallel
um that's what that's sort of under the
hood what uh read sql table does this
work was led by
a handful of engineers led by martin
durant at anaconda
this is this works um but uh
it does have some cons it's slow because
it's backed by
odbc
it also doesn't support complex queries
you can imagine if you had two tables
that you want to join together and then
query that you know result and maybe do
some other operations sort of the actual
final table you're interested in um it
it can be hard to determine what sub
queries uh sort of construct the
subquery is to uh sample that table and
parallel i also have the risk of
inconsistent results if you are making a
query on a table that someone else is
writing to at the same time you can
imagine how you can get uh inconsistent
and consistent
results the next option is using dask's
delayed interface uh so this uh
the the good folks at saturn cloud have
put out some documentation around how to
go about this approach as well
this is great in that it supports uh
reads and writes and it's actually
relatively straightforward to read
you're just writing some load function
which you run in parallel
um
this is sort of doing um a more explicit
version of what's going on inside
dask's read sql
table uh again it has a similar um
uh
sort of downsides to this approach that
it's it's
backed by uh odbc so it's it's can be
slow it doesn't support
uh complex queries and you also get the
risk of inconsistent results it does
require some manual sort of effort so
you can you have to build up all these
subqueries manually which often requires
some knowledge of the underlying data
set that you're trying to trying to
query but this is really great for
educational purposes i think it's really
explicit and clear as to what actually
is happening under the hood
uh the next option is to take your data
set and just export it to some you know
file dump basically you can take your uh
taker query and uh get their query
result and dump it to a bunch of
csv files or dump it to a bunch of
parquet files in x3 you can then use das
and other technologies to
use these standard file formats read in
say a data set of parquet files on s3
um
this uh is
really uh
fast both at reading and writing because
all these technologies have focused on
for instance formats like parquet and
and the i o uh with with those file
formats
um
the the downsides here is that you're
sort of copying your data sets so uh
this can lead to you know data bloat uh
in your storage systems you also now
have sort of multiple copies of your
data floating around it's hard to tell
where the uh source of truth is you no
longer have a single source of truth and
in general your database admins will
just be sad whenever you are uh sort of
replicating your your
nice database into a dump of parquet
files
um but this is a a valid option
uh
so yeah sorry i forgot there's a code
sample here to show you how to you know
copy in a data set from a snowflake
table into an s3 and dump
arcade files
uh so what we so this is sort of some of
the existing ways in which uh you might
have in which desk and snowflake have
been integrated in the past
so today we are excited that there is a
a new path forward with this distributed
fetch capabilities that mark talked
about
um so today there is a das snowflake
package you can install you can
grippercon to install dash snowflake and
have snowflake
used under the hood this utilizes
snowflakes new result batch technology
so we can
have fast parallel reads it will auto
partition and it does support complex
queries as well
and because snowflake is managing this
data uh we're not like say dumping to a
bunch of parquet files snowflake is able
to do all the things it's great at it's
able to handle automatic cleanup and
life cycle management of your datasets
so i want to move on to a demonstration
real quick here which highlights uh
death snowflake in usage so here um
spinning of a gas cluster this happens
to be using coil but this could be any
gas cluster
um
moving on a little bit
uh here um we are executing a we're sort
of setting up this large group here to
execute on some data set in snowflake so
notice this isn't a you know from table
select all this is a complex query this
is like a big system here
we can then use dask's read snowflake
function here which takes in a query and
actually returns a das data frame
so here we're executing this query we're
sending this query off to snowflake
and we can see uh
starting to appear in the snowflakes ui
the query has made its way to snowflake
this is again this larger
complex query that we'd like to have
happen
um snowflake then
you know sort of uh does its thing and
we can see uh the
all the snowflake you know the execution
the sql execution optimizations
happening
all in inside snowflake
and what we get back is a das data frame
so we get back something that we can now
sort of uh hand off to the pi data stack
to start doing all the normal pi data
operations we're used to doing
um so for example we can
so here we can see things appearing in
the das dashboard now
we can do things like train an xgboost
model so here we're setting up our rxd
boost model and we're starting to train
it on all of this data that we're we're
getting from snowflake
so um that's sort of how we can use desk
and snowflake right alongside each other
looking under the hood a little bit um
so what happens is worse you have your
das client sitting sitting here i hope
you can see my mouse i'm moving it
around the dash client
um so what das will do is we'll send a
that sql query to snowflake
snowflake will then send back metadata
for all of the individual chunks in your
in your gas data frame
so das will then take that metadata for
each of those result queries and send
those off to workers in your cluster
those workers have been able to each
independently talk to snowflake and have
the results for each of these chunks
sent back from snowflake snowflake
efficiently using pi aero
because data are rather because
snowflake is managing all of this data
access here it's able to clean up
automatically and all is right in the
world
so uh just to sort of summarize uh
things real quickly
so snowflake is a fast and easy sql data
warehousing service uh it's great at uh
as we've said um sort of data storage
sql queries um and desk is a general
purpose distributed computing framework
we've now engineers at uh at das and
snowflake have built a bridge between
these two technologies allowing users to
really have the best of both worlds here
if you're interested in trying this out
you can pip install death snowflake or
go to
the desk netflix repository there to get
more information from the documentation
if you have any more questions about
desk feel free to join das community
slack channel we're linking to the
invite there in the slides
and with that i'll maybe bring miles and
mark back if you have any questions or
to answer questions from users or from
attendees
so thanks james miles and mark uh we
have one question in the q a here how
does this compare to snowflake plus
spark both from a support and
performance perspective
management i'm not sure if you want to
take this i'm also happy yeah yeah sorry
i was just unmuting um
so actually
um our spark connector works very
similarly to
to
what we exposed
and
and so kind of the python work is
um
it's loosely based on
what spark
does uh and you know the obvious
the
performance we can talk about python
versus uh
versus uh java right
or i'm sorry it might be scala but
um you know like those sort of
constraints still stand
but we
we did everything we could to make this
as performance on python as possible so
i i say it's comparable
and and you guys
obviously know what that means for
python
yeah and maybe just to follow up on the
on the support side of the question um
you know depending if you're if you're
managing your own spark cluster or
if you're going with a managed service
like data bricks
you know there's obviously kind of
implied cost for that snowflake is
is 100 self-managed um you don't have to
worry about
you know what server size i'm going to
choose etc
and then for desk it's really a
lightweight a much lighter weights
you know framework that you can also
bring to your kind of infrastructure of
choice
um and and we've really optimized the
the connection between the two using
using the arrow format now
there's nothing stopping you from
bringing spark into that equation as
well if you wanted to
um but in general what we've seen is
from a support perspective
that you know desk is super easy to
manage
snowflake is managed for you um
and so there's not all the overhead of
managing these spark clusters which you
don't know how to size exactly
and those costs can run away from you
great guys we're out of time now so if
there are any more questions for miles
james or mark please
ask them in slack
so thanks again guys and i'm going to
stop the recording